هو كان قبل يمكن اجرا مباحثات مع رئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس واتناولت المحادثات
قضايا عده في مقدمتها قرار القياده
الفلسطينيه وقف التنسيق الامني مع اسرائيل
بالاضافه الى قضايا اخرى مثل اعاده فتح
القنصليه الامريكيه بالقدس الشرقيه
وانسداد الافق السياسي والاجراءات
العقابيه الاسرائيليه ضد السلطه ومنها
احتجاز اسرائيل عائدات الضرائب الفلسطينيه
المستحقه عليها لصالح السلطات
وخلال لقائيه الرئيس الفلسطيني في مقر
المقاطعه في رام الله شدد الوزير الامريكي
اوتوني بليكن على ان واشنطن تعارض اي
اجراء من شانه جعله تحقيق حل الدولتين
اكثر صعوبه وراء ابلنكن ان هناك افقا
منحسرا من الامل بالنسبه للفلسطينيين يجب
تغييره
من اي طرف يجعل من تحقيق حل الدولتين اكثر
صعوبه وكنا واضحين بان هذا يشمل اجراءات
من قبيل توسيع المستوطنات واطفاء صفه
الشرعيه عليها واعمال هدم البيوت واخلائها
من ساكنيها وكذلك تغيير الوضع التاريخي
القائم للاماكن المقدسه وبالطبع نعرض ايضا
الدعوات لممارسه العنف والتغاضي عنها
[موسيقى]